what in the world is this yeah so the
other day I was scrolling on Instagram
and I noticed a hashtag called hashtag
vagina gay obviously had to click on it
and it turns out there's this whole
internet trend where people are baking
these cakes in the shape of vulvas with
like babies eggs coming out of them I
saw one I knew I had to buy it and make
my co-workers try it so I ordered one
and I'm expecting it any day so I just
got the cake and I have to say it is
frankly more graphic than I thought it
would be shaping more hyped and not
really good I never knew a vagina look
like this and I'm a lesbian guys I've
seen a lot of vaginas in my day not to
like brag or anything this is like
childbirth meats aww I'm a mom I have
given birth even looking at it now I'm
having like flashbacks this is trending
this a lot of people do this our vaginas
that big is this there is a butthole
what I thought someone just accidentally
like poke the cake no fatten anus kind
of also looks like intestines stuffed in
there
I do yeah this feels very like
Rosemary's Baby it's good that is good
cake
that's awesome first of all if my vagina
was made out of red velvet I'd be happy
to thanks great honesty pubes are my
favorite part not gonna lie you know
it's cake you just like slice off the
top half and then it's fine but in fact
I'm about to be an auntie in a day or
two so I will actually be witnessing
this now I'm not really that excited
about it anymore
I feel like giving birth is like super
metal cuz it's just like yeah [ __ ]
did that there's a baby there's a whole
egg coming out of that's freaking crazy
man women are superheroes kudos to
whoever made this cake you artistic
gross genius you
[Music]